in this video we would learn about the
concepts behind salting in and salting
out in biochemistry these concepts are
pretty confusing and people don't have a
clear idea about this so stay tuned at
the end of this video because at the end
of this video it would be totally clear
to you let's say you have a protein
solution and with this protein solution
you are going to do two experiments in
the first set of experiment you have
added a salt solution where the ionic
strength is not too high and you have
noticed that with mild increase in the
salt concentration the increase of the
solubility and there is no visible
precipitate in this tube and everything
is soluble in the second case you have
added salt solution which has very high
ionic strength and it's very
concentrated solution and in this
particular case you have seen without
increasing the solubility the solubility
is dramatically decreased and there is a
visible pellet in cell as well so if you
plot the graph with solubility versus
the salt concentration you initially see
a increase in solubility with increase
of salt concentration but later with the
increase of salt concentration there is
a decrease in the solubility the first
phenomena is popularly known as salting
in with increase of salt concentration
there is increase in solubility and the
second concept condition is known as
salting out with very high salt
concentration the proteins are
precipitated out but have you ever
wondered how this thing actually work at
a molecular level so you want to
understand that you need to know about
the protein structure a little bit so
you know in protein structure there are
many ions right and there are many amino
acids which could be charged for example
they are expert ador glutamate which
could be negatively charged there are
also possibilities that there are lysine
arginine these kind of basic residues
and based on the pH these residues would
be charged so protein would have some
charge on it right it's totally
legitimate
now salting is salting in is the
phenomenon where the increase in ionic
strength is actually increasing the
solubility constant
or increasing the solubility of the
protein so how does that happen
so this effect is only and only observed
in lower ionic strengths and different
for different proteins and a debate
huckle theory can actually explain the
phenomena so let's look at it so at very
low salt concentration let's look at the
molecular interactions inside the
solution so this is the protein it's
negative and the positive charges are
kind of masked by our salt counter ions
okay and now these salt counter ions are
effectively masking all the different
sort of charges of the protein and then
the solvent ion in this case the water
is actually creating a hydration shell
around the protein and you have more
solute and solvent interaction than the
solute solute interaction as a result
the protein is nice happy in this
environment and soluble you don't see
any precipitate and you say the protein
is Sol Sol even right but imagine a
situation when you have added too much
of salt let's say in this case the salt
is NaCl and that's why you have so many
these na plus ions
now this na plus ion would love to
interact with water molecules and the
protein is somewhere ignored so very
less amount of water molecule is
interacting with the protein and try to
create the hydration shell around it and
try to solve it it rather all of these
water molecules are interacting with the
sodium plus ion or the salt ions so here
what happens in short is as the sodium
ions are taking away all of these water
molecules our solute particles that we
know are protein particles are
interacting with one another and the
solute solute interaction is much more
than the solute solvent interaction as a
result the protein gets precipitated so
that is the concept behind salting in
and salting out so in this situation we
are going to call it as salting out
and you can see the visible precipitate
in the protein right now what we learned
from so far is at low salt concentration
the protein is effectively the proteins
charge is effectively masked by the
counter ions and the hydration shell is
nicely formed around it as a result this
protein is soluble but with very high
salt concentration all of the solute
molecules are interacting with each
other rather than interacting with the
solvent molecules so solute solute
interaction is much more higher than the
solute solvent interaction as a result
its spirit is precipitating and there is
some series known as Hofmann stir series
which actually tells us that using which
type of salt counter ions we can
precipitate what type of proteins and
actually this is a very crude method of
protein separation because different
protein has different solubility and
using different salt concentration you
can precipitate different proteins based
on their properties but that requires a
prior information about the proteins
ionic situation otherwise it's
impossible to know and which range you
need to solve I mean to precipitate the
protein and separate it out so that's
why it's a very crude method as well so
I hope this video was informative and
quick so if you liked this video give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe but to leave a
comment at the end of this video because
your comment give me so much positive
motivation to make more such videos and
do let me know that what other topics
you want to know about in biochemistry
I'll make videos on that thank you
thanks for you thanks for your attention
and listening